[Musique]
les marseillais après vingt ans de
réflexion dix ans d'études et quatre ans
de travaux sont aujourd'hui les premiers
français de province a voyagé en
mettrons un métro qui sera bientôt aussi
célèbre que la sardine qui bouche à le
port la trilogie de pagnol et la bonne
mère
remettront qui reflète également un
choix politique
c'est d'abord la musique a été décidé
seul moyen
seul moyen je le répète et
éviter le blocage complet de la
circulation
passer d'une ville très ancienne nous
jugeons très étroite il fait donc un
mode de transport
souterrain
j'ai pu penser un mode de transport
aérien il n'y avait pas la place et donc
construire un métro c'est ce que nous a
décidé
l'idée de base du métro c'est de faire
gagner du temps et de l'argent aux
usagers chaque jour 7 marseillais sur
dix se rendent dans le centre ville pour
travailler une concentration qui rend
les embouteillages inévitable fait
gaspiller 350 mille heures chaque jour
et perdre un milliard de francs par an
aux exigences du terrain près le métro
suit les grands axes de migrations
quotidiennes schématiquement un hub
paris du nord est vers le centre entre
la rose et castellane par saint charles
et le vieux porte avec un prolongement
vers les caillols du nord au sud entre
arenc et mazargues par le prado premier
tronçon mis en service six kilomètres
entre la rose et saint charles 26
novembre 77 3 km entre saint charles et
qu'arsenal famars 78 pour le reste il
faudra attendre les travaux commencés le
13 ou 73 ont duré trois mois de plus que
prévu
une opération doute moins cher pourquoi
la ville de marseille at elle choisi de
garder la maîtrise de la construction du
métro alors qu'il aurait pu faire une
concession ou un fermage la paire maj
leur a permis de réaliser aucune
économie au contraire
vous voulez vous que la société privée
bénéficiaires de la congestion de
l'affermage nous fasse des cadeaux ça
n'existe pas
en conclusion nous mêmes le métro
un exploitant
y comme au contraire des changes de
faire des économies économies qui
bénéficieront aux contribuables
marseillais
et il a peur du vide ça dans la
construction du métro au départ l'état
avait promis une subvention de 50
penchant pour lyon et pour marseille et
pour nous un peu marseille peuple cette
subvention du fait des hausses du prix
de la vie défense qu'il ne s'appliquait
pas à tout ce qui concerne la
construction du métro est tombée à 24%
et puis toutes taxes comprises à 21%
c'est à dire à très peu de choses si
médecine charge très lourde pour votre
municipal georges énorme pour des
messies parité c'est une démonstration
de plus de la mauvaise politique
le gouvernement la france est le seul
pays en europe dans lequel le
gouvernement conserve pour lui
l'essentiel des recettes fiscales dans
tous les autres pays et collectivités
locales mais l'épée si d'une part des
recettes fiscales ou de subventions
1 milliard 250 millions soit compte tenu
de l'inflation 3% de dépassement
seulement par rapport au budget initial
il est vrai aussi que rien n'est
révolutionnaire dans la conception même
si tout est ultra moderne dans la
technique lors du lancement de concours
nous avons admis toutes les suggestions
possible de la part des concurrents et
ils se trouvent au moins à cette époque
en 1971 que le seul système proposé a
été celui du remède au métro
ceci dit
il est tout à fait classique certes
mais il utilise toutes les touts les
perfectionnements que l'on a pu
déceler ou mettre en oeuvre dans les
métros étrangers construit jusqu'ici
c'est à dire que c'est un métro qui est
moderne mais que ça ne se voit pas
absolument pour faire un système de
transport
qui est utilisé par des milliers des
dizaines de milliers d'usagers chaque
jour il faut avoir un matériel par
particulièrement fiable on voit que le
pilotage est un pilotage automatique
est-ce que ça na pas certain risque que
pour lüthi l'usagé ça ne pense pas
quelques quelques angoisses et
provoquera quelques angoisses en vain le
pilotage automatique et maintenant à
l'épreuve dans plusieurs métros du monde
c'est certes une nouveauté de ces
disons cinq dernières années
mais tous les métros actuellement en
construction prennent le pilotage
automatique qui s'avère en définitive
comme le système est bien au point plus
sécurisant qu'un pilotage manuel
[Musique]
bien reçu baisser si je respecte le dso
départ sur ordre
ce pcc qui donne les ordres le poste de
commande centralisé c'est le coeur du
métro des contrôleurs et règle le trafic
et peuvent correspondre à tout moment
avec les conducteurs notre voyage va
nous conduire de saint charles à la rose
6045 mettre cinq stations souterraines 3
en surface
première halte réforme est décoré de
dessins à d'arbres parce qu'il y en a au
dessus de nos têtes et que l'on a trouvé
des troncs silicifiées pendant les
travaux
jusqu'à shaft rue les rames circulent
dans des boyaux distinctes ce n'est
qu'ensuite que le terrain permet des
galeries à double voie chaque convoi
peut transporter 350 voyageurs dont 40%
à 6 contre 25% seulement à pâques une
seule classe équivalente à une bonne
première
fréquence une rame toutes les 3 minutes
aux heures de pointe toutes les cinq
minutes le reste de la journée et puis
si le trafic ne nécessite une quatrième
voiture par ram et une fréquence à 90
secondes
la conduite est encore manuel mais dans
un an elle sera entièrement automatisée
réglée par les ordinateurs du pcc le
conducteur sera pourtant toujours
présent dans sa cabine prêt à pallier
les insuffisances de la machine
d'accord
après ce voyage coloré qui nous a
conduits d'une le violacé aux roses qui
rien c'est la rose le dépôt central avec
son garage couvert pour que les rames à
l'arrêt restent fraîches même au plus
chaud de l'été et son atelier
les mécaniciens marseillais les
techniciens venus d usine de
valenciennes effectuent les derniers
réglages
les bogies d'un type nouveau monté sur
thématique garantissent silence et
confort et permettent au métro de
grimper des pentes exceptionnellement
raid
les moteurs sont alimentés en 750 volts
continu conduit par le rail de guidage
reste à savoir si ce métro exploiter
directement par la municipalité ne va
pas s'enliser dans un déficit chronique
dépenses de métro sont constantes en ce
sens que le matériel et le personnel
utilisé les heures d'ouverture sont les
mêmes quelle que soit la fréquentation
des usagers il est donc certain que si
les premières années
l'équilibré d'exploitation sera
difficile à atteindre dans une dizaine
d'années à francs constants les dépenses
restant constante et le trafic pouvant
progresser de 30 40 50% j'espère bien
que l'équilibré sera atteint pour cette
première de
[Musique]
ce qu'on prendrait le métro de marseille
lorsque turku bras
[Musique]
d'ailleurs nous alloue
des chartreux à la gare sacha quel moyen
de transport vous employez maintenant
j'en crois le bus
[Musique]
pour moi ce n'est pas du tout
intéressant
manurat du tabac afin de monter vous
allez les eaux payer ce métro oui
brûlés ou bauma jouer n'est pas du côté
de la route là je suis à château comme
l'air
apparemment il est bien j'espère qu'il
en restera longtemps avec la vie des
clients mais pas peur qu'on écrive un
peu sur les bus
si
on voit la population de marseille
comment la ville
je ne prendrai avait mètres de mon
travail me laissera avec maître de votre
domicile
vous semble le plus pratique que
l'autobus ah oui je prends
ce fier à paris c'est intéressant
il faut en effet convertir les
marseillais au métro pour les habitants
de larrau ce sera facile car ils
mettront trois fois moins de temps pour
gagner le centre ville mais les autres
un plan général de circulation est à
l'étude les conseillers municipaux en
délibérerons bientôt et peut-être
sera-t-il en place pour le printemps
mais dès à présent les réseaux d'autobus
ont modifié dans le secteur nord-est
pour être complémentaire de ce métro
le métro qui était un élément linéaire
ne couvre qu'une petite superficie de la
ville de marseille et son impact serait
réduite à cette superficie s'il n'était
accompagnée de mesures concernant le
réseau de surface
des mesures dites de rabattement en
termes techniques et qui consiste à
aller chercher dans les quartiers
périphériques un autobus et voyageurs et
de les ramener à la première à la
station de métro la plus proche dont
comme un ruisseau qu'on ramène de la
grande rivière exactement on gonfle la
grande rivière avec une série de petits
ruisseaux est précisément la mise en
service de la première ligne va être
l'occasion
pour tous les quartiers nord d'est
d'une révision du plan du réseau de
surface
de tarifs à retenir un franc 75 le
parcours simple bus métros trams 2
francs 35 le parcours combiné avec
possibilités de correspondances pendant
une heure et une nouveauté la carte azur
qui permet de voyager sur l'ensemble des
points réseau pendant un mois pour 85
francs mais ce tarif sera-t-il celui de
la sécurité des voyageurs dans les
couloirs et sur les quais
c'est l'état et qui dispose de la police
ne sont pas les municipalités et par
conséquent c'est la police d'état qui
devra assurer la sécurité dans le métro
mais comme je considère que j'ai une
responsabilité morale on peut la
responsabilité juridique bien entendu je
ne peux couperet de la sécurité dans le
métro je ne laisserai pas les choses
comme le fait le gouvernement à paris un
métro confié ton cou sens civique est la
vigilance des marseillais on ne
comprendrait pas qu'un tel effort
financier et technique conduit à bien
pour le bien-être des citoyens ne soient
mis à mal par quelques irréductibles en
quête d' acte gratuit
[Musique]